yeah welcome to this game against just
wrong on five minutes blitz game and the
Queens gambit the triangle variation
let's see if he goes here he goes for
the notable okay maybe I can play some
sort of gambit out of this some not
exactly the most testing way to combat
this opening but maybe I'm an
interesting way to play for a change I
want to play with b3 here trying to play
against the c64 start with this and yeah
I cannot really play p 3 it has always
got before and c3 now this was probably
very bad bad opening choice okay but
them try to fight here
yeah I don't really have any substantial
compensation maybe I can go night in
form and then be three some are opening
up against the c6 bond
he probably just can play c5 and it
didn't do that okay come on let's open
this up he can take here and take with
the with the night but I hope that this
is some enough compensation I can
actually take c6 here because of of the
night f6 check yeah let's do that
now of course you can just move the
Queen oh yeah yes surprising shouldn't
be too bad for me at the office decided
I mean it was earlier in the blunder or
if or there may be a form
need to use some the pieces that I've in
play here attacking e6 fetching d6 I
think he probably needs to take it I'll
play Knight c5 first then take it but at
the end i am attacking f7 song but some
it's not so that's bad I'm night c5 and
maybe even go to air three this looks
like a good idea actually let's go here
takes Bishop takes I can't play 96cm oh
really you allow that so that surprises
me because now the night is so unstable
where does it go
Brooke
okay let's um let's protect this and
make the Queen mobile ok taking the a
poem
wait if i take it be three rupee six you
can play be to win okay okay let's let's
just block this and to win the deep own
without any big concession on the
airport I mean if you having rook a
sexist my next move unless he do does
dad and then I think I thought rook a
five yeah okay five growing the porn
e 6 is bad okay just just just return
this makes sure that the two parts are
not connected kt7 now
me6 and then you take t6 I don't know if
I cannot spend spend many much more time
yeah this is this is the problem raining
I can play e6 but it's not helping
and damn tending of 5
yeah at least I get some activity five
looks dangerous now we'll be fine from
the other I wasn't a steak yea rather
substantial mistake probably yeah yeah
now he's got the moves and threatening
all kinds of stuff check check check
yeah this was probably a bit unlucky
frame I don't know with good good play
can certainly for he can certainly about
this I don't know I mean at least in
blitz chest it looks very very tricky to
to play for what okay the computer says
I'm winning all along but I don't know
yeah this is really I'm losing all right
thanks for watching